so I want to start with a very
interesting very interesting topic today
maybe it's going to be tiny bit
challenging but we can try it could it
is intermediate moves how do you
remember we spoke about intermediate
moves in the campaign a bit yes
what are intermediate moves do you
remember are they going to be forcing
moves intermediate moves they should be
so not only what are fall singles to
move such as
would each perfect a check a check is
forcing well by the rules of the game
you you have to do something against it
right block move the key in capture you
have to do something okay so check is
the most forcing thing because just by
the rules you have to do something what
else you won't tell me a threat yeah
that's that's usually very forcing right
right it's threat and the higher the
threat is the more forcing it is right
if I threaten my opponent Queen pretty
much 98 out of 100 99 years to do
something very some situations you can
yes maybe a stronger threat to example
what would be a stronger threat than
taking the Queen yes exactly so you
tighten your opponent Queen but well he
is threatening checkmate so you can
actually ignore your threat exactly so
we know about checks creating big threat
the higher the threat is the more
forcing it is something else that is
actually happens quite a lot the pretty
much force is the one perfect that it
checks captures ends threats that's it
like you give a check here let's just
put it on the boat super quickly even
though it is not smart way of playing
black has to have two moves to play can
either move the skin or take the bishop
most likely will take the bishop by the
way does it mean that forcing moves are
good always our forcing moves good
not at all here this was a very forcing
move is it a good move it's a very bad
move right now another type of forcing
move will be for example this Black has
many many moves to play but if white
captures how many moves like really
should consider now yes
to mosrite which are they six exactly no
much thinking you just know
automatically my opponent captured the
piece well if you can and shoot well
capture it back so that's the part of
captures and the part of threats for
example again not a right way to play
but I know I've seen me well pretty much
many many most kids I've seen dot this
type of play okay why does a very storm
threat awright what is White's threat
yes Queen takes f7 checkmate that's not
a bad to attract mate so what would you
play with black
yes
nitro eight-six is a possibility no not
my preferred one but 926 is a
possibility I agree yes move the pawn up
and I assume you mean this one right
that's probably the best move that's a
very good move
it helps us tiny develop if we want to
put the bishop there and more
importantly it's taking the Queen and
then well really we understand why as
the opening principle we don't want to
get the Queen out so early because the
Queen well pretty much anything that
will attack it the Queen will have to
move somewhere so that that's exactly
this idea pretty much anything that
attacking the Queen the Queen will have
to move somewhere exactly okay so it's
easy to fall something but it's not easy
to it not necessarily means that it is a
very good thing
so for example I want to let you think
for one two minutes but I want pretty
much everyone to make effort to think
what should be White's best move
yes you want to take the night right
what do you think your opponent will
play if you will take the night yes so
if you'll take the night what would be
preventing I know right from the bishop
to take the Queen right so Bishop takes
Knight the Queen will be lost
so the knight is not protected this is
correct this is the most important part
of the position yes Queen f1 check and
what's your idea after black king is
gonna move that's exactly the idea we
want to take the knight but we have a
problem right now
the queen is under attack but if we can
move the Queen in a falling way right if
we're gonna play Queen here it's it's
going to be good enough saying hey now
we're gonna take the knight what do you
think the opponent is going to stand
there and say oh please come and take my
knight the movies Knight is going to
maybe take the bait shop it's gonna play
something so that's the power of fall
signals
we're going to move the Queen away from
being captured in a check the King will
move doesn't matter well and you won the
night excellent job so forcing moves and
that's what we're going to do quite
right now okay
white is to play here
do you know okay so we'll give everyone
one more minute to think and then you
can answer me okay
do you want to tell me what yeah yeah
yeah oh one second Kate yes I told you
you know I mean I said it a minute ago I
cannot break my words in one minute so
what what you what would you play with
white knight okay now let's think
together you wanna take the Queen right
in chess do we have to think about our
opponent move or can we play only
thinking about our moves how should we
play chess we have to if not we are
playing you know impossible to play
without thinking what the opponent will
do right and the more you can do it
ahead the stronger you are if you can
say well I can see what I will play and
then what my opponent move will do
that's one move ahead what I will play
what my opponent best move what my best
move but my opponent best moved it's two
moves ahead you can do it many many
moves ahead you're stronger plan right
there further you can do it the stronger
you are so you want to take black screen
right well what do we think like is
going to play black is going to take the
Queen right did we exchange Queens did
white want anything nothing so let's see
9 X Queen Bishop take ok we just traded
Queens of course 90 Queen is the first
move everyone's thinking but the queen
is undefended
yes don't tell me I know you can it will
be too difficult to move it will be
difficult to move yeah that remind me we
are almost about time for lunch right
eating okay Wow okay
eating the black Bishop okay so black
we'll have to take the Queen right and
then what is White's going to play take
the Queen so in different form the
previous position both Queens are off
the board but on the way instead of
white allowing these to be captured for
free this would be would be captured
right and I need to check here but white
one a night that was very that was our
idea and by the way what was the
intermediate move here
it was check queen takes bishop on e7
check okay let's look at the following
position white is to play here
Queen takes Knight it's very very good
move very good move if we will take the
Queen block we'll take the Queen we just
traded but if we will take the knight
again with a check take midnight one day
night for free so that was another time
that the Queen's were under attack and
one of them moved with a check okay next
position is tricky that's a good that's
a good position why it is to play here
White is only one move you might think
that that white is more than one move
but white is only one move to play here
idea well let you answer first but I
want to see more hands okay
idea what is your move okay then I have
a question you want to play work take
work and the king take bishop take right
that looks like the most reasonable way
to play but there's a tiny trick here
when you take the rook why can't black
capture back with his bishop and then
you have no bishop to capture on GFO
right black will capture back with the
Bishop rook b1 check very smart move
very smart move so the rook is not going
to be captured yeah the work is out of
c1 excellent there are two possible
moves to consider we know that we cannot
take the bishop because then our work
will be captured because black is
threatening to capture their work so we
cannot capture the bishop
the big trick is that if we take this
Bishop goes back and now we don't have
we cannot take it so would be one is a
very good move King they can go
somewhere and everything yes okay what
was your idea
if the king take this is what I decide
if the king take then you will take the
bishop but what happen if the bishop
captures okay hmm missile takes we're
sorry that's how it works
yes okay that's how it works sometimes
okay let's see another position with
many many many many captures okay why
just to play here
was this your move was this your move
okay
if the knight takes the knight what is
they gonna play you can just say they
should take bishop if the bishop take
the bait shop
well 9x9 so that's just nothing so we
kind of find a way think about it it's
like you push a pause button like say
okay but your opponent has to play what
you want you stop its plans check I
totally agree with that
exactly exactly that that's exactly the
idea now let's do something more
challenging so we understand that we
have to look for checks as a way to fold
something forcing our piece to move
somewhere for avoiding an exchange
avoiding losing material but sometimes
well it's actually the later one is a
bit more difficult for example why these
two play yes exactly
mm-hm did I say checkmate in one I said
move for white and preferably play the
best move
No yeah
you see sounds okay so what do you see
so okay that is stout that's an
excellent start that's how we think
let's do it together perfect
so first anyone if you started playing
chess a week ago you know how the piece
is moving and you understand you started
more than a week ago and also me but
let's say that we did start a week ago
so we know that we want to take the B
shop right we want to take much we want
to take capture it's fun but then the
opponent to play 94 well this is a bit
annoying for tiny bit why why would you
move the Queen up checking exactly the
right way exactly very good that's
exactly the right way so we understand
for what but what we did you we were
actually thinking here like chess
players because what we were doing we
will take the same let me see my move oh
it looks so pretty so great I'm going to
take the bishop not saying oh I'm going
to take the bishop here hi and that's it
stop thinking that's not the right way
we have to think what the opponent will
play so once we understand it okay it's
not working we cannot take the bishop
immediately then we say okay do we have
a way to avoid look look what we need we
need to avoid allowing the opponent this
but we still want to be able to capture
the bishop you can say hey this is a
good move we'll put our queen in the
center it looks so pretty well just
exchange nothing right we just exchange
no nobody want anything but if we will
use a forcing move intermediate what
does it mean intermediate it's between a
series of a sequence of moves so it's
somewhere in the middle intermediate we
will give this check
and now we will take it and we want our
material and one day game that's very
very good way of thinking okay
interesting black to plain I want you to
think carefully oh let me actually flip
the board okay so now everyone's you can
play black black is to play let me just
see the tie define it correctly perfect
you tell me what is that if I'll tell
you then what what will be my job I'll
be asking and answering myself this will
be boring
although I do it sometime but that's
another discussion yes
Luke sistex
and my why box is safe
ah good word and why couldn't we just
take and then take the book and then
take the other work this yes why you
will take you will take this work and
then when it takes we're going to take
this work for free now yes so we will
take this one you will take no why now
huh
the bishop not my the bishop will take
very good exactly
don't don't always believe my tone and
what I'm saying right it's not my job to
help you my job is to make you learn and
think better not that's the beautiful
take exactly if the King take then what
I pretended before was correct but the
bishop will take and after take
that's just exchanging that's correct
because the bishop is capturing for
example if instead of a bishop we would
have had a knight here then it doesn't
matter then you can just take and then
take or check and then take it doesn't
make any difference because the rook on
f1 anyway cannot be defended very good
okay let me put this position for you we
will play many different versions of
this one it's like to play first of all
it's back to play so what seems like a
good move for black here
d 5 why do you like d5 Fox the bishop in
the night that's a very good movie looks
like it is it training material yes no
wolf we'll see it's a folk its exact
like a for speaking about lunch
ok so what do play after d5 I will let
you answer but one second I know I know
that you know why to play I will see two
three more hands and then you will
answer me okay
yes 95 tightening treatments so far so
far pretty much everything that we have
discussed where what checks check moving
a piece with a check capturing a piece
with a check
anything that is immediately focusing
but we said we have captures and
threatening checkmate or threatening hai
pieces look that's excellent
by the threat of a checkmate
does anyone by the way knows what's the
name of this checkmate yes exactly
by the threat of this checkmate black
has to do something you are forcing him
to do something and then you're just
gonna move the bishop exactly yes
here for example look FA try to move the
bishop okay
white save this material okay now let's
say that this is the position and it's
black to play and black play this move
is black winning now material is now
black winning something
yes daddy which movie what would you
play now but then you will take the beer
shop fork aha
so by the threat of weaning material the
impossible - black - taotie not advice
for black - to take right totally agree
okay black to play is this move winning
material for black or not
No
now why not what will the play exactly
exactly
Bishop g6 attacking high-value piece so
we have seen threatening a fork or
threatening to attack captures checks
all those we've seen as a way to let us
win material all right white is to play
you're gonna tell me what white should
be playing here I'll give you all one
two-minute you already know
we're gonna tell me no okay
don't buy show yes
h ho
perfect very very good it's not only
that you suggested they move I mean
normally it would make sense that you've
seen the idea but you exactly explained
why you play that that's how Chester
would think right what god no that's
exactly why not because what's your name
yeah even that's exactly what even said
exactly he explained he was like sitting
here standing here and exactly doing the
thing that was very very good basically
what he said is dude if you're going to
take black will checkmate we have to
think what black will play if we will
take we asked ourselves hey there is a
rook for free beautiful big party but
what happens if we take it if the point
is nothing well most likely we're gonna
win the game right we took a look a lot
of material for free but we have to
think what the opponent has well the
opponent is tiny checkmate only
checkmate so then even said okay I want
to take the rook this is our problem you
know I I will tell you when I was your
age I remember my mother was telling me
about problems in school like tests you
have to understand first of all the
question if you understand the question
you will get the right answer how many
times they tend it happens to someone
did well they are super smart but they
just example forget what is exactly the
question like they think for example
once you will study in math well what
was the speed of the car you will solve
the problem but actually the question
was what was the distance so you told
everything perfect you should just said
oh well the car was going 40 miles an
hour and did five hours so you just need
to do okay the distance 200 but you just
didn't read the question perfectly
that's what chess is about soon right
now we have a question I want to take
the rook and I want to avoid checkmate
how to do it that's where this moves
comes through cage for the rook is still
under attack in the h1 square
defended seriously that logic and
comparing actually they did bazillion
researchers I'm not going to be here
lecturing about them but the way of
thinking process thinking in chess to
solving problems to many many academic
things in school and it's very very good
actually but you know I'm not a preacher
about those things but I can tell you
that it's quite correct white is to play
White's to play
yes
no it's okay it's okay say move okay
well why be okay so but you can tell me
why not to take the work immediately
that was your idea
exactly very good exactly if we will
take very good so we'll just play first
check give this square and then take the
root and this will be a very classical
intermediate we will do what we yeah
yeah you're right
I mean all right this this move will
move back and then it's checkmate that's
correct
all right so two things we've seen here
do you have a question but but black
black work will take whites work I mean
it will be blacks to play right I mean
you're attacking you are attacking the
works but it's blacks to play whenever
we play something the most important
thing forget about intermediate moves
any puzzle thing what my opponent is
going to play
what were your points going to play we
you never play alone never right so in
chess in any other thing you are but
chess is kind of simple because it's
just one opponent you and your opponent
not well five different parties then
it's much more complicated well what
this will doing this and this and this
too complicated but just a simple you
and your opponent so in that sense you
know that if you will take your opponent
will play this move so how you defend
what my opponent is going to play and
how can I force what I want to do okay
we will do way more puzzles in our next
classes I'll see you next Sunday